we're all in prison you know I mean kind
of right it is kind and Frank would say
hold my closet New York they're in
prison like I talked to New York people
they're like in prison and they're
scared and they're scared well these
people getting it over there like a lot
like you California's got like 27
thousand cases we got what forty five
million people in the state you know New
York psych it are we rolling - rolling
New York's on top of each other though
they know where to escape I have people
there that have not been out of their
physical apartment in like 30 days
that's so nuts that's crazy go crazy
dude cradles you know who's the MVP of
this whole corona [ __ ] yeah the governor
of New York he's a fool rate is like him
so high yeah you should run I feeling
with serious [ __ ] you know this is yeah
I don't I just cannot either they're
meatballs you know down hold it charlie
yeah yeah you know we're gonna it's like
first of all the guy sure closed New
York early I didn't close it now
everybody's sick then he then he did
closer to a week later and then he takes
credit for Chloe it's like we can't win
in politics I know why am i why do I
have to like him that's my whole thing
like why not crisis do I have to go oh
yeah this guy's a genius
I mean it's like the guy his brothers in
CNN but I need the whole brother I don't
like I don't trust Italians at work for
the government that's the Italian should
be criminals hey when they work for the
government it's crazy because it's like
they are by their nature a criminal race
I have to say that your what are you
saying in their hearts like if you were
to examine that I do beg be very
scientific Italians Italians it's well
known the Italians God took some of
their brain and put it in their penis oh
well no this is facts okay it's well
known and I have a lot of Italian
friends are good people but I just don't
trust them when they're on the side of
the government I'm like wait a minute
what politicians do you trust none there
you go not really about their talents
here's my whole problem Oklahoma this is
really my ol hole a show called I
thought everybody loves him now I gotta
go to because when everybody loves
it's not that I'm a criterion I'm a
thinker so I'm like why does everyone
love him I get nervous why is everyone
loving huh he's the governor you
shouldn't love the governor right you
should be like wait a minute that's the
guy that enforces the law what if it
would hold what if he was Irish since
you've turned this into a racial well
the Irish are meant to be they were
meant to work for the government cuz
they're also not right but hey like Jews
and wasps are really smart Irish people
are meant to like work for the
government or tell stories later it'll
like Irish people can either tell a
funny tale or hit you with a club okay
that's two options for the I so would
you have a caste system we're depending
on your blood this seems very yeah have
you seen como and him and his brother
one on CNN and they're out there and
they're like talking [ __ ] that's what
I'm like it's like but this is the thing
why don't these other governors figure
it out and politicians like we want to
see the real you you don't like Gavin
Newsom you say he's a [ __ ] but listen
here's the thing here's why I like we're
gonna be shut down till [ __ ] you but
dude that sure if if I Drive I wha
I mean I kind of like I don't feel shut
down no not either yeah I don't feel
shut that even though that businesses
are shut down but here's a question on
the news today wasn't there they report
that wait which news are you watching I
was CNN oh I know but but but it is but
the statistic says and I don't know if
it's true gala seeing that in a month or
in two months the corona virus killed
more people than the flu in a year true
or false
oh yes what did depend what what ratings
they're going off of list if they are
the Florida is a test case Georgia is
the test case Georgia's opening up
restaurants Monday so is Denver shows
Texas
cello's Ohio people are gonna watch
those states now listen hey I hope I
hope there's not a bloodbath but if
there's a bloodbath people sit back and
go okay and if they if those states it's
not that bad
then you'll see the country start to
open up yeah my thing is I don't know I
don't know that we can afford to do this
much longer
rinoa no we can't and all the sizin go
through the roof domestic violence know
so many issues we can't do that much
longer and I also listen I don't know
how many people I think maybe maybe if
then there's a ton of people that feel
like if you look at certain areas and
you're like okay New York is slammed
certain areas just slam then you keep
them closed for longer now again this is
interesting I don't
this is a website that I'm not even sure
about National Review right it's it
there right but by the way and I don't
want to sack Alice here I don't but
thank God like think about imagine it
didn't like where the great we're almost
did a great department you mean like you
know what I mean let it be worth it
another I mean the reality is where we
take tens of millions of people don't
have jobs if it I don't want anyone to
die but if this was a nothing thing
there would be riots in a total melee
yeah the other thing that Street again I
hate to be the the skeptical hippo here
but the other thing with the corona
deaths is recently anything that dies
any person that dies the track helps
Corona
so when you talk a lot of these doctors
they don't know exactly I'm sure a lot
of people I don't a lot of many see what
spooks people out is every now and then
you get a young healthy person in the
hospital uh thank you later that's
always the case with any that's always
the case with any disease that's true
but that's what because other diseases
we've made peace with this is new so
like it's new we're like [ __ ] we don't
want we don't want to die something a
flu killed sixty one thousand Americans
do on 79918
you ever see a Washington estimated
kovin nineteen would most likely kill
about sixty thousand you got that that
yeah I mean a lot of people I think
right so did yeah we don't shut down the
whole the argument is that the flu
doesn't double me six thousand one cuz
we keep talking micron I'm gonna slit my
[ __ ] high now I know they say no one
wants to listen to it a lot better agree
I agree well let's get back to your
racist the funny faces are different
when the funniest post the I do great
finally selling [ __ ] tickets and then
the first year anyone gave a [ __ ] and
now it's just that you shut that I loved
your your post my sister my sister sent
me your post of just making fun of
celebrities about the sacrifice well
yeah because there's a lot of people
that are out now being like it's time to
just heal heal your body heal your mind
yeah take a breath
somebody I was literally like centers
Italy and she's like take a breath at
you guys just be just be I'm like you
know we could just be people don't have
food they you don't people honey for
when living with three people yeah
meanwhile
just breathe Schwarzenegger is heating
this meal right sick kitchen with his
two miniature ponies yeah have you seen
this yet Bogey's they're both me those
guys stay at home they both must stay at
home yeah I'm be safe I'm just eating my
you know eat good food mmm all right
come on dude it's so yeah it's amazing
watch this it's pretty cool estupido oh
those race is the greatest it's the
greatest is it I was on Instagram
account I bet he hasn't touched those
things in years they hang out with him
all the time he shot them in the head
yes see now 65 unit a lot of the house
and in my California so you stay home
and behave here yeah you got a lot of
this a terminator shirt I don't care
he's great come on do it
you ready hit man well yeah a lot of
these people are like who's that Tim I'm
that far in their console Elgort did a
naked selfies to somebody online just
put my head on and I just great pose
yeah this is again out celebrities are
helping it's like hey I'm naked in the
shower
hey sorry you're eating your grandma but
I'm naked in the shower and I won't be
enjoyed by last time we talked -
speaking of eating you were on a keto
diet I was on keto diet how'd it go it
was you know here's the thing that's
clear here's what I learned very quickly
the keto diet
what about as good as mine well here's
the thing with the keto diet we've never
been sicker it's very hard to you know
do it cuz I because what happens is you
start making little you start making
little adjustments sure and they become
large they turn into boulders they turn
into real problems
turns into real if you first start she
had shut
catch so catch up just started I said
you start on the children - so right so
I was like I could just have a
cheeseburger give a cheeseburger but
what if I just use a little like I
literally I started I swear to God just
being like like a little like I would
just - - no yeah she can I say
cheeseburger you're not having the bun
right no no it's a burger no cheese I'm
not an idiot
I don't know so I when I was
doing it I was really trying yeah and
then I a little ketchup and then when
you have a little ketchup you you're
like something awakens in you yeah
something awakens oh you mean your lot
awakens we like this yeah the demon
awakens and it's like hey I bet you
could have a dash of something else yeah
I'm like I bet you're right and then you
start because on the keto it's like how
many carbs a day is supposed to have
like it's like it's a very low number
but it's a good certain amount of
training your last there's one of your
last right which is Sarge take a bite of
a cracker but in your head you're like I
I could have a little taste of a lot of
different things and it's 20 or less I
started chewing things and then spin it
out yeah yeah Oh dark chocolate okay
because it says it's okay you can't have
a whole bar don't brag but I would
harass you you have to have a tiny
little bite right before you go to bed
or something cuz if that's what keeps
your thing going on that and then I
would just be like I would just have a
bar and just kind of fight you know what
else I found with keto is I found myself
eating a sh way more calories than I was
eating on a regular diet but I'd like to
it's ketosis all fat and protein but
still 10,000 calories 10,000 calories
and I gotta just stay home carbs 10,000
calories 10,000 I gotta stay away from
carbs and sugar just for the most part
because like that's my problem my
problem that's everybody's problem -
everybody's yeah but they say calories
have different hormonal effects in your
body right they do for sure but if yeah
but if you're eating a shitload I don't
care what dive you eat a lot of counting
a lot of color and you're not burning
it's a problem yeah yeah yeah and the
keto thing with me is there like you can
eat cheese so it got a little ridiculous
a little ridiculous I all got a little
absurd yeah - I was eating cheeses that
don't even go together - I was eating
like cheddar and fresh mozzarella every
I was just like this isn't even real but
you know I watched Anthony Bourdain and
he had at one of his no reservations on
Sardinia yeah so Sardinia is some
beautifully and they live the bits it's
one of the blue zones they live forever
there's literally like honored yeah if
you see the way they eat they in for
they oh I don't know [ __ ] sausage
every meal right big wheels of cheese
and red wine yeah really my [ __ ] is my
fresh [ __ ]
dude they make their feta right there I
mean it everything comes from right
there in their garden honey problem is
so hungry watching it you all they're
eating they're eating so much of the
things they tell you not to eat and they
eventually I want to slam my door found
it all having and they still later all
big they're all the interested there are
farmers all right but you're saying
they're like shredded no they just built
to be fat and then died live forever
they may live forever but they don't
look great
well but at the same time they live did
I started eating this me when they want
old yeah yeah yeah but then so then they
go right out slobber you go Rio sauce
has no carbs or no sugar and it's just
good right and it's really good it's all
right so it's like I was like okay what
if I were to drink it like what happens
is you start you start using so much
like copious amount go to Bristol Farms
and come out with nine Rayo sauces like
what do you do are you like you own a
Canadian company I started OD'ing a
Buffalo cauliflower and then yeah pine
nuts yeah hi not to provide the bags of
pine nuts you know any calories in just
one cup of pine nuts like 800 there's
not even tire like that to Martinez is a
lot of people getting depressed and it's
easy to eat when you're depressed so and
when you're bored nothing right yeah so
I've now try to eat better because I'm
like I could really fall into a problem
here being in the normal brother and
like just is it there's like you me have
the same inner demon
well we it's just it's just I like to be
on the go I like to be moving I like to
die was like free I you know I could you
know three months ago or two months ago
whenever I wanted I could just whenever
I got bored I could kinda I was always
on the road but I could fly anywhere I
wanted go to New York go to Vegas go
anywhere
do a little stand-up do whatever now
it's like yeah now it's all taken away
and you're like [ __ ] who your podcasts
are booming your pod roaming doing
booming great but I mean lifestyle was I
wanted me know I pause listen and I
thank God about that because I know a
lot of other people that are like you
know they're in trouble with their
highest iPod death like how during the
coin yeah they're trying to start one or
they're they're like oh let me finally
let me let me see what this podcasts all
about work into this podcast it has
ninety seven hundred episodes no one's
listened
it's got four ratings in 10,000 episodes
let me really start focusing though it's
like sometimes happening to me where I
think just being inside I start to panic
at night at night when I there's nothing
to do that's when I'll I'll be like
maybe I'll drink all the wine cuz the
day makes you feel the Sun makes you
feel good yes and then smile oh yeah
that makes you feel grad love the heat
see I worked so much the other day by
timing it tonight I'm pretty chill yeah
that's the hall move because night is
where the anxiety comes yes if we're not
if you exhaust yourself no you have to
be exhausted ya have to be exhausted
I've been working out twice a [ __ ]
day and yeah I get so tired and I I
found myself needing at least a half
hours of sleep yeah you slipper now
that's sleep more but here's the other
thing we're probably all healthier now
cuz we're not on a plane all the time as
I was saying with Rogan like I've never
felt better physically I felt better and
I actually feel the wrath I didn't you
know I'm not staying out late I'm not
the only time I drink is when we do
podcasts about three times a week but
yeah it was the era's a night to weed
ugliness [ __ ] when they open [ __ ] up two
people run back out or people like yeah
tiptoeing I'm right exact I think that
well I'm gonna run back out but I think
looking at society to me a slow drizzle
I have a show and smoke in end of June
yeah that thing is booming nothing's
selling yeah we were always a little
dicey at things booming Spokane's a good
times meth town but also watching the
meth and heroin town meth and heroin
which I celebrate but watch out was hit
first when I was ahead of the curve
there's not enough Spokane us flying in
Spokane coming you know I know I told
and I started to look at the hills and
it's kind of pretty and you know it's
the Washington Forest all the [ __ ]
and then you start as you guys at planes
landing you start to get close you start
to see like microwaves and refrigerators
like strewn on the side of this mountain
and you start to see little encampments
of people and they're like yeah that's
meth town no people just live on the
hill I love it no it's great it's it's
what needs to happen it's a good room
too and they're green rooms the best
with all the candy and sannyasi all
right that's right they have the video
game where they don't spoke in then they
own the new one that just opened up
opened up in Oklahoma City Bricktown
comedy club and they own one more forget
we're but the it'll be interesting
see if we are a photo can't they're
gonna allow that to go down in truth I
hope they can I show ya what's going
down and are you gonna wear mask to
Washington State yeah no yeah yeah but
talking to the owners and they'll talk
into the the the state officials sounds
like it should be a good let me ask you
a question
Georgia opens up Monday could you go
down in the Atlanta punch line and do a
show on Tuesday if I would I'm just
wondering if you if we'd be allowed cuz
restaurants open up but I don't know
when comedy about playing there though
you know I'm saying that flight anyway
you could anyway now you're just gonna
be the only the biggest issue is the
biggest issue is legal so for arrived
for now for productions right yeah so so
Frank was talking about this when when
you are a producer and you're gonna do
movies yeah in a lot of countries see
the United States we sue we should look
in other countries they're like we're
ready to rock and roll here right but in
the United States you're dealing with
lawyers who suck a dick and so what
happens is and the Disney's like this
nobody else well how do you open up when
if somebody gets sick they're gonna give
it to their grandmother and that grandma
dies it's a wrongful death suit they get
a [ __ ] that's so much [ __ ] money
it's a litigious Carnival Cruise I like
they're looking at 12 wrongful death
gonna have to sign the thing
so we're also scissors should go away
though you know sprite for the best when
people walk into your show I would be
surprised if they don't have to sign a
thing that absolved you're gonna have to
have that and I failed to be willing to
yeah what else 1832 anybody that is a
[ __ ] anybody that's gonna walk in and
and and and you know you sign it and it
is what your actors on a set so we're
talking about this persona back well
it's there's a way to do we're going to
create our way out of it so it the crews
gonna be a skeleton crew only people
that have to be there right they'll be
in masks and gloves and then the actors
have to have a test pretty much from
what I'm hearing every day it may be
that we have to get our you know finger
pricked every day or swabs every that
the end of the world it's not but it's
just what's gonna it's gonna be the new
normal for a while now the question is
any mayor it draft us on Thursday you
[ __ ] yeah your football fan terminal
yeah a little bit not crazy but they
said
you know a lot of people I don't know
man what a lot of people are saying
sports aren't happening a lot of people
are [ __ ] idiot
because it's just baseball's gonna go
down in Arizona I love friends I come
back I mean I hope you're right listen
I'm not I hope you're right odds are
myself I'm just hearing a lot of and I
know that we're all hearing a lot of
things that are far bleaker than your
pictures well I hope you're not saying
sports come back but I'm not saying
there's gonna be a crowd there they're
gonna come back oh oh okay well then
yeah well then we yeah yeah I'm talking
about the people in the stands it's
gonna take a little while well they're
not gonna let them I mean not for a
while yeah not to me about football
things to me okay when does the next
time somebody feels comfortable sitting
in the original room in the comedy store
next to a stranger who they don't know
breathing next to them for an hour
that's the question my end of June Healy
I bet I bet by July I say July listens I
think maybe your mouth dead odds ears I
know there's a vaccine and when that's
pop that seems that's in the ears maybe
okay but then when they when they have
treatments that actually work and
apparently antivirals at work yeah yeah
this hydrochloric that's a little have
an issue some years of issues your rent
as if here's a good one at a Gilead I
bought a little bit of that come on and
you know the [ __ ] name of them yeah
well I just bought some of these but the
highs real stuff have the hydro in the
z-pak but didn't that I heard that
doesn't work it works on some people or
some people some people help some people
nobody knows anything about this [ __ ]
tank we don't know [ __ ] nobody knows
so you're Chinese terrified yeah that's
smart they're far for you guys yeah for
you remember right all right dude thank
you I don't know I think things are I
think it may things are slowly start to
come back I don't think it's the only
body test a real hopeful I think they're
ones we took yeah Wow let me tell you
set you up with that because I know
here's my team's a bit of a health
professional I am a virologist
I'm an immunologist and a resolve
genealogist I have you know many people
are my work done you know I worked on
Ebola I worked on Ebola under the
Obama's I didn't know that a job were
you on the n1 n1 - I was on h1n1 there
you go thank you I was on which is swine
flu yeah
a lot of I did a lot of work on SARS one
Wow so working all that okay please keep
talking well the reality is I forget
everybody that goes to organs [ __ ]
things- by the way you don't think that
[ __ ] just put money in his
pocket he's like another negative one
Joe go I mean come on
not one positive well he's very
interesting maybe none of us man yeah
probably immune slashing tell Fergus I
was just hoping I had I had the antibody
i standed - I was gonna fly - Wu Han and
do a video eating a bath i wouldíve
tried to go viral nobody got viral
yeah real soup can you get it again on
maybe everyone's like maybe get it again
associate in the bat I don't know man
I'm just I like going to someone's house
now because I forget that this is a
thing when I'm in public I see the masks
I'm like I'll [ __ ] we're in trouble I
can't stand when I go to somebody's
backyard if somebody's grilling a steak
I'm like everything's fine yeah it's 90
degrees I think is fine have you been
around when you're not wearing a mask
like I just walk people dude people yeah
but the [ __ ] you lookin at dude I'll
work up the street man I've been tested
to get freaked out at the gas stations a
little never with the nut that I just my
sanitized right after I touched them I
wash my hands yeah you know I have to
say I'm not so much how personalities
like I see a guy walking and he's with
his girl and he's kind of like he just
she's just kind of like a bit like with
stooped posture the man wearing a mask
and this was before we were supposed to
wear masks and I was walking with a
friend of mine and I go you want to kiss
him with a gun guy yeah [ __ ] yeah I'm
such a dick about it and I'm not I'm not
I think we should wear masks obviously
if the CDC says we should inside that I
get it you see that one video [ __ ] which
one see the video I sent it to you where
it's before a press conference and
someone in Trump's I said we've all been
vaccinated yeah I mean he was like
Hughes I don't know how about we goes
you'll need to wear masks mortality
rates 0.01 we're fine I don't think he's
joking
who dude is weird because like listen
then you hear about some fitness trainer
who's 37
like what but I guess that's everything
you're always out with everything here I
would aspirin asking how many honeybees
aspirin kill 35,000 a year
check this out that's high 35,000
aspirin aspirin I just took two today
35,000 people watch this watch how many
people died worldwide a year in this
country that's in this country and in
this is when you're having rumors [ __ ]
bro science now if they get a good
antiviral that keeps people out of
hospital cuz that changes it everything
oh that's gonna be money damn tobacco
kills four and thirty thousand off
cancer and it's [ __ ] worth it alcohol
hundred ten thousand prescription drugs
thirty two one sec okay that's right man
so prescription drug that that's what I
mean when you see somebody over a
certain age really enjoying a cigarette
you're like oh this [ __ ] has
made their there like they don't want
another way
no like somebody that's really older
just going at it you're like oh yeah
there's you're not turning my grandpa
died of lung cancer
yeah because they were chain smokers
right English they smoked non-stop in
the house I got a brown smoke definitely
gonna die from it but they smoked
non-stop
I remember my grandpa was on he's on
oxygen they told me cannot smoke I'll
die and they said you can't smoke in the
house my grandma be next don't just they
didn't give a [ __ ] still smoke you sure
still smoking sure yeah it's a bad life
it's a very bad addiction my money back
up I used to smoke was younger I smoked
for about six seven years on and off and
then like every now and then now I won't
do it every now and then I would have a
cigarette in the comedy store parking
lot but I would never buy a pack or
anything but now I now I won't do it
because of the respiratory fire it like
now I won't do it in England and but I
got to a point people like oh you can't
have a cigarette every now and then it's
like you can Gerry started smoking again
at 55 yeah he started he's overweight
not yeah and I go what are you doing he
goes yeah no I haven't smoked in 15
years and in those 15 years not a day
not a day out of Jade's and I think
about smoker you do you know it's
interesting what it takes over your head
but like I saw somebody smoking on Santa
Monica Boulevard and I'm driving and I'm
looking at them and I go you know here's
the thing with cigarettes man cuz I
stopped drinking - I never
well I don't you get all I just ten
years I don't look at booze ever and go
I want to drink but my cigarettes
never looked bad they always look good
because it's so like hey I'll just do it
and I throw people on you look I can
walk away the people usually do you
don't see too much I'm gonna be smoking
these days
Wow they day which is coming we're gonna
find out in five years that's justice we
know that's horse yeah I mean that's
gonna you know but I now let you see a
lot of hot people smoking
I remember when as a kid again my
grandma straight British accent
everything they would call their
cigarettes fact yeah when I was at
school they would call the kids [ __ ] so
just the contact I I didn't think it was
a fence because I thought like a dumbass
their timeout cigarette yeah right
that's weird you're like and I learned
the difference three months ago usually
your mother's born and raised born and
raised yeah so are your family's British
half well my mom my mom's that is my dad
yeah German Italian and a smoked Asian
smoke dude Asian hey Jill Slava same
smoked no everyone else in my family
does that they love sing and you know
what they love to see you know I love a
Marlboro light that's what Asian loves
right they love a Marber elective the
supreme race they get it right well
races Supreme Italians have I'm an Asian
supremacist not a white sorrow I don't
know how used to walk around Chinatown
just going like this alright yes like
you they like me cuz I look like a guy
in a movie if you're a fat white guy
know what we're in Asia they think
you're in a movie ok so they're like oh
yeah this is he is from the show so the
Italians are natural criminals you're
saying they have I probably all of
criminal DNA you don't trust me real
criminal DNA there's nothing wrong with
it you have a little bit of crab there
is something wrong with respect Italian
because I don't really I don't like the
government I respect people who try to
get around to God you would never let in
the time in government if you had your
well I don't trust them because I know
when I see an Italian in the government
I'm like they're running the game I just
I'm not in on it right I was in on it
the Asians should be running every well
the because they don't and this is gonna
sound controversial it's gonna sound
controversial pepper and racist but no
it's not it's really not
in science they're less emotional people
they're just not the Koreans very
emotional but Chinese to me not emotion
emotion so many people to cake it is
what it is go to Chinatown you see them
all working you're like nobody's like on
the phone be like you're gonna call me
back like it's never happening they're
working and their day should run it all
because they they are less emotional and
that's a nice way to sit wasps less
emotional Jews less emotional very
emotional not and nine really yes a
little bit but he did a little bit you
like it doesn't derail them Irish at the
rail let me give you an example yeah let
me give you please because this is good
science I know people that Jewish people
that are in business with their dad or
its business with their uncle and then
they bring an outsider in that's really
good at business and then like one of
them gets in a fight and then the Jewish
dad or uncles like hey listen like we
need that outsider they're very good at
business and there's somebody be like
but I'm your son I'm your nephew and
whatever and they're like gives a [ __ ]
like we're making money here it's about
money
yeah it's not about you know Irish
people will be like yeah [ __ ] that
outsider let's run this into the ground
ourselves
that's very true yeah so that's the
whole thing is there's less emotion in
in a place like in in the the Asian
world not all of them the Korean girls
are very giggly right they giggle a lot
they're very giggling so it's not it's
not racist because racism would be all
girls are fair is he went on Rogan stood
spitting out some fat yeah wrong goes
where you getting that I was right
pulled over he goes what are you getting
this information what you got why didn't
bring the [ __ ] divers also make a
joke and I can't think of the site yeah
I get first of all I love it it's like a
city Bravo friend from it like there's a
million people on that show Hillary
Clinton snorting babies and it's like
okay well just
nobody's asking how about we ask for a
source on that you know I don't know I
hear [ __ ] and I'm a man of pure source
mind and body and soul I take just a
two-hour flight which is fine all I said
was the gates goes into the third world
and every now and then he pricks
something and sometimes it works and
sometimes it doesn't and I'm right about
that
that doesn't mean we don't need vaccines
that's right it means that I'm right
about that him and Melinda go on a
vacation to the third world would a
needle and just sit there and go are you
sure that's how it's done I feel like
your sis is exactly how it can you show
me the technique Oh to an underdeveloped
country and they go and they have like a
fake carnival okay and and and then
people are brought to them people are
brought to the carnival and everyone's
like having fun everything like that
and you know that thing where they throw
you know the carnival game they throw
the dart into the balloon yeah
then what happens is while you're not
looking bill takes the dart he goes I
guess that's what happened and sometimes
it works and sometimes you know what's
he putting in the kid anything vaccine
to see if it works and then sometimes
the kid turns into a werewolf sometimes
that's what it is you have a fax lady
where anyone listen do you believe in
pitha gate them some of it I wasn't I
wish you have art on your [ __ ] walls
of kids and cages something's wrong well
they don't have that there by the way
yeah buddy some of those do Tony Podesta
Livia's our collection there's something
weird yeah but the Cosmo piece is what
it's called where pizza gets comment to
Pete's comment that's yes have you been
there no I think great food I got shirts
good I got older he was hot it's good
for business he was heartbroken with it
and he goes they they say that but I
also feel like he was there's no
basement they don't have up he took they
say the owners getting blown by a kid
he's looking at Brandon he's like I'm so
heartbroken by this whole thing
Brendan's like he's a good guy he took
me to the basement it's go ahead go in
there and it was a he was a rich but
here's the thing
I don't know that piece game
particularly but rich people [ __ ] kids
and here's what it is
there are rich men all of them at
not all of them Brendon but there's rich
people Jewish and they get away with it
and people cover it up so right then and
they awfully happen who covers up child
crimes though there's other people that
are committing child stories extra the
Catholic Church come on pedophile rings
they exist I don't know I'm not invited
to them but I'm like to say that none of
your letters to say that none of them
exist is crazy I agree I agree with a
lot of people like their own exist at
all they busted a huge online pen
already clearly don't be like that
none of those people that get to that
level of power they don't care what goes
on Dana human life means nothing to
those people Obama Hillary any of them
Trump when you're the president you
you're pressing a button and vaporizing
in town you don't you're not thinking
about individual human life you barely
catch sure so they're not like so if
they knew something was going on they'd
be like well you know yeah I mean it's
like what do you expect you know I think
when they when Clinton bombed that they
what they thought was a chemical weapon
yeah I'm gonna ask her in factory yeah
it was but there was an aura they knew
who was working there and they were like
we got to make a choice here
well they say the same thing with with
Trump when he killed that uh was it
Iranian or Iraq official Mir that the
money that guy saw so Danny had been
they all told not to in trouble with a
massive story be well he was amassing
the video and Allah no I didn't see I
felt like [ __ ] standing up shouting
the US but he was right he was my for a
lot of walked into a guest house if you
walked any one of your friends house
sure and you're sitting there eating
dinner yeah and there's a photo on a
wall of like kids in cages and weird
stuff wouldn't you be like okay like you
feel weird put on is actually his real
if that's real are doors that's
conspiracy I don't play this is all
Internet [ __ ] right no I mean what does
that mean it it's on the Internet dude
that's that's hard huh this is Podesta's
the artist that this guy uses all the
time and he buys their art so it's like
he just buys creepy [ __ ] now it is what
it is that's a little creepy
what the [ __ ] is that that's the artist
that he uses all the time I don't know
is that true yep attest article I mean
he does use that particular artist who
does specialize in this he does well I
mean it's weird stuff I mean I'm not
saying that all gothic art is bad or all
dark art is bad but it's just weird to
be in a house where you know well some
of that's a little weird right cow it's
pretty [ __ ] hard not to look at is
this right okay that's an [ __ ] you'll
end the episode by buying pieces that's
weird
look at that baby mermaid that old man
mermaid look at that [ __ ] yeah yeah
we're gonna buy this stuff it's great
this is fantastic phenomenal that's
actually I've changed I want that in my
eye look at that you guys that's
hilarious look at that that's actually
an old man mermaid is good that'll make
me good that's really creepy well yeah I
mean I don't know if you want that in
your hat look at that that blob with the
diet [ __ ] [ __ ] oh yeah there yeah
that's a just have yeah interesting
I'm just saying listen man get that
scary it's that scary [ __ ] super scary
you wouldn't you just wouldn't let him
babysit that's all well think about the
guy who's like not thinking about that
he's like I'm gonna come on yes [ __ ]
that the art that man is yeah yeah
that's what I mean what then again what
maybe that gonna be dark it's okay to be
afraid of the world yeah you know but
you but you're not gonna create
sculptures that insinuate molesting kids
no no no unless you were my dad as a kid
or something well that's all things so
the conspiracy is that there's some
subterranean layer of existence or
whatever where this stuff's going on all
the time and then this art is like a
reflection of what's happening and
that's really crazy and I hope that's
not the case well dude I'm surprised on
children it's real it is so real and if
you were to be Internet now there are
some crazy number of images crazy Amaris
did this thing and not only that the
worst part is we don't really have
enough of we don't put enough resources
into stopping the show yeah dude and and
it's so much worse than you can imagine
and you don't want me to for kids like
there's no like article in you know
rolling stone being like you know like
big up the kit it's all about like a
400-pound woman who's like stop it yeah
but it's not pick up any magazine is
except girl is like ninety eight hundred
pounds is she's like top that's the
headline and you're like all right and
then you open it up and she's like they
wouldn't let me on a rock this is an
outrage you know it's a problem surprise
always a woman who looks like like me
but inexplicably worse she's like wants
to be a Disney Princess it's like what
do you what no dude I don't wonder why I
don't get brought in for the roles it
Ansel Elgort I don't it doesn't keep you
up but now it's not so healthy give her
baby drive with a naked kid on my
Instagram good looking good great
[ __ ] sure I said we're just some
really but like I don't work comes work
though it's like I get why I'm brought
in for the roles I'm brought in for
dockworkers generate gambler father who
can only sees daughter when a cop is
present I know I'm not like sitting I
don't show up every day to Ford models
going like what about you know what
about me so I just don't know that's a
whole movement that plus model thing is
that and it's okay not to be it's a you
know it's just not my thing I do you
mean get yours girl get yours is exactly
right that's gonna be a new man say New
York that feminists wrote a book called
the beauty myth which is like everybody
read in that whole circle on it's like
saying that you know the idea that a
woman has to be like symmetrical with
curves is what about fat women it's a
myth and we've been taught it meanwhile
they did these studies on even
congenitally blind men prefer like a
small waist to hip ratio babies
everybody dot listen here everybody
wants somebody but that's why you
develop personalities that's why you
make money that's why you it is what it
is you're not gonna redefine what people
are attracted to you find a way to make
yourself the best version of yourself
you can be that's right that's correct
that's what is it good events for us to
have you had any work done
I've had a lot of work done I thought so
I actually am a Native American woman
okay are you sure I was in the Native
American woman they made me into this
okay because it's comical they gave me
this voice to give me everything so you
wanted to be an IKE in LA as a from
Arizona as in small of webapp webelo a
small miniature American woman's on the
desk if this is a Kido show I'd like to
thank you though sure I mean what is
that muffin let's try it right man I
never had a baked good what is it how
does it feel in your mouth it's amazing
it's chocolate banana walnut muffins
she's got a fries gotta have one can we
try one gotta go for it she's like it's
a coronavirus chocolate walnut muffin
moth break race will take over well the
best underwear period army undies and
here's why they last I've had all
different kinds of underwear name the
brand and they never last me undies I
don't know what they do with that fabric
I don't know what it is but they last
for forever and that's why all of my
underwear
if you ain't lying mom I got mine right
now dude for no sweating yeah sweating I
don't feel it weird the way dude
they're the back they're so comfortable
I sleep in them I ride my bike in them I
swim in them yeah you can't wrestle I
swim in them I was at my sister's in EM
I didn't have my didn't have my bathing
suit and have your trunks pulled up pull
my pants up and I my butt my piece look
good Miami undies mm-hmm it hugs him so
they look like stylish European
underwears that's cuz me undies are made
with stuff sustainable fabric and
available in size extra small for you up
for me for XL for me
yeah from black to unicorn me on these
prints are made for your self-expression
alright and you guys give me undies
first time purchase you get 50% off and
free shipping this a no-brainer
especially because they have a 100%
satisfaction guaranteed Brian me Andy's
[ __ ] [ __ ] spiders what I'm saying for
50% off free shipping hun percent
satisfaction guarantee that's my undies
calm slash biter
through the Athens you never get him did
you do the economy store a benefit less
I did was a real disaster I heard is a
[ __ ] show only because listen that you
nology is not really ready for that and
it's not great because there's a lag and
people are talking over each other does
a [ __ ] show but they raise money so
that's a good thing yeah oh there's no
rapper on it I feel really good thank
God
that's what I like I'm like looking at
around my kinda rappers but this is what
I mean
a white chick would have had it would
have been rappers and it would have been
a mess
Thank You Vietnamese don't believe in
that see no emotions no rappers think
I'm good about it did you eat today I
just had a water and a little you know
for Firoz do I keep the back door even
this is good because what's good is when
I taste the chocolate I want to live
have you had a you know last meal what
would it be
you're gonna die you can have anyone
else in a death-row show here's the
thing right I think about that every
night no I would I mean I would start
with a shellfish tower I'm talking about
chilled lobster shrimp crab and I would
have a creamy cilantro sauce I'd have
some cocktail sauce I'd have a little
office is noise yeah nice advice who's a
horseradish in it yeah then I would move
on to like a New York Strip rare awesome
hash browns a little creamed spinach
some steak sauce and then I ended with a
hot fudge sundae that's not a bad that's
my meal I probably might not actually
move ice to move dude I was watching
this show it was on it's on Netflix when
they're big new documentaries this drug
these are [ __ ] weird getting they got
convicted of straight up they're going
to prison for life and then this new
group goes in and looks at all the facts
of their their trial trying to get them
out of prison because you guys were
wrongly convicted but it's crazy but the
one guys gets life and they showed where
he was gonna go to get [ __ ] you know
put to sleep I was thinking how can you
imagine the night before no yeah oh I
want to Sardinia I want before I die and
I just want sausage lots of cheese bread
and wine it's gotta be weird
are you hungry and do you even enjoy
come here for a fight you can't eat
through the roof they should do it they
see people could you know what happens
they say when they accept it that well
they say that um when you're gonna be
taken to a more time who said 1d they
were they've did these studies they said
when when someone is going to be
tortured they know they're gonna be
tortured they're waiting in a Cell or
they gonna go to a firing squad they
fall asleep they can't say wow
their body gets yeah that was a lighting
to your nerves are so bad so I'm going
to get real drowsy you get really drowsy
huh your body just gets you know yeah
you I've seen that happen to you yeah
just like I'll sleep in the back that's
what's driving it with nuts about like
the quarantine is like I talked to a guy
what's work the prison says because he
goes easiest guys in here lifers because
they've accepted it music it's the
uncertainty of when you're gonna get out
and stuff that can drive people crazy
give them anxiety because they're like
what the you know because they know that
there's an outside crazy
you're gonna clearly accepted that they
don't know when you know they like the
parole hearing coming up like he's like
lifers kind of accepted and then they
just so like even if they told me if
they're like alright listen it's gonna
suck but August 31st you're out of this
yeah I'd be like alright I'm doing a bid
I'm like in jail they say then they
always have the same and says don't do
the time yeah don't let the time do you
you do the time right so what they'll do
is the guys I dream in line know this I
know people I've talked to people who
spent a long long time in prison yeah
and what they'll do is they they
schedule every [ __ ] minute
interesting cuz it makes it pass yeah
because what you do is you schedule
everything so even like tying your shoes
I'm waking up putting on your clothes
you go your work out let's have your
breakfast thing so so they get super
[ __ ] regimented really regimented um
how do you keeping your space in your
area clean drinking ups the Netflix talk
is the accused type in new to the times
in that time don't you you don't let the
time don't you don't want the time to
you you do what's always about this this
all at the time do you
it's 2020 tune uh that's right you do
that time yeah man how do you explain it
to kids
you both have kids how do you explain
this to kids do you go listen guys the
country's a little sick okay I say do
you deal with that sickness so much so
my kid you know
other days pop I won't see my friends
only go to school I said sickness is
still here
the sickness here so we can't leave we
got to be safe right now the sickness is
still here so yeah like you want to go
to Disneyland like cats is that the same
thing you just kind of got sick my kids
are my kids are older today know
everything like they just know that
there's a virus in it you know it
doesn't affect kids typically and they
know that there's just rule it's almost
like kids now have lost on the kids I
have the upper hand because if you're
like you say anything wrong you know my
daughter said you know my daughter said
to me the other day she goes I said
something like no I said something like
yeah you do that and that crack it you
know joking around
yeah she goes yeah you cracked me and
I'll call child services how's that
sound yeah what good for half the upper
hand that's what kids do that's it the
innocent files so so it starts with
these two gentlemen who it's horrible I
forget where it's at
but two little girls with like two weeks
apart when they were sleeping got
dragged other house raped murdered and
drowned in the water at least that's in
this area and but they had bike bite
marks on them that they thought there
were bite marks so there's this forensic
genius who specialized in bites and he
goes oh they took who've it like people
who visited the house they took all
their bite marks there's only forensics
they could do so this guy goes that was
without a doubt this is the same teeth
these are the bite mark he bailed so he
went to prison for life next a week
later little girl dies the boyfriend was
in the house they go let's see your bite
marks is her bite marks on this girl the
same oh this is the guy without a doubt
this the man prison for life twenty
years go by they look at that guy's
information they know he's full of [ __ ]
they're like these bite marks if that's
not how it works so we go back to go
through all the files all the case files
and now they have DNA because science
advanced they look at the science and
these guys were innocent they get them
out you know what you know what the
government gives you for doing that time
twenty years in life they give you fifty
thousand dollars a year for ten years
then after ten years
those guys are [ __ ] because they have
this on their record they can't get jobs
there so fun I know a guy who got twenty
five million though though for doing
twenty five years so he got a lot of
money but
one in general yeah sure I believe
Zeenat great believe they give you the
Trump my story but yeah here no no but I
mean I'm sure whatever this thing's so
dark so now what happened
could they never catch the guy dude you
kid there's a prisoner yeah and he he
was on he's on death row and he admitted
to the murders you can have one video
going yeah I killed those girls ago why
did you do this the demons in my head
were told me to do it they go both girls
is yeah yeah they're telling me to do it
he was how did you get him and he goes
through the exact step-by-step he was a
lot I looked in the window I saw a
little girls thing next to the window on
the bed so I just broke the window
grabbed her rushed her out
dude you can't even tell that story you
can't even tell that story at a job
interview like as as like a hey man my
life went sorry no he was like you run
you can't be like hey wrongly community
think I bit two girls and killed them
like oh here's the deal one here's like
oh that's sorry that happened also get
out of here's the energies if you're
planning to watch this
don't listen this in three two one the
bite marks you know what they figured
out what it is you toss them these like
little pawns or the the lake there
behind the house you know what it was
fish they weren't bite marks
it was crawl fish does the bodies hit
the crawfish would bite you know by its
what now this just became like a happy
New Orleans story
well what a fun way and I wrap it all up
you know this is why I have dogs yeah
have you been watching stuff we even
what do you been into I started binging
the Americans on FX
oh really I auditioned for that I worked
so hard it was so it's so good so it's a
great it gets a little repetitive around
season four or five but then it wraps up
its really good Larry Russell and
Matthew Reese and they're just killers
man my buddy directed the pilot for that
one that first came out great
oh I wish I were three days will be his
role for that main role yeah I worked so
hard on it and then my buddy said
through my other friend he goes Bryan's
wasn't that good in it I was gonna do
another party he just wasn't good in his
audition I was like okay dude this guy
is great yeah [ __ ] that comes from a
[ __ ] the Getty family [ __ ] off what's
the Getty I love you lead the guy and I
had such a crush on her like I love her
think he's a good actor though and then
he came I want every role that I'm
supposed to get close to Fortune theme
stirs so the reality is it Everett he
came in like he came to my house cuz we
were watching the fights we had on Chael
Sonnen fought over the second time he
was there and my wife my wife at the
time no my wife at the time thought she
was oh my God he's so hot
and she said so I hit noe they beat me
out in the part but also he's quietly a
girl and then my wife was obsessed as
well worse he was now Wow even worse
he's Welsh even worse he has an accent
and the whole thing that he's younger
yeah whatever I yeah I was confusing him
with Balthazar Getty but yeah that's
right he was there I'm jealous I'm
jealous that he got the part I'm jealous
that I was told I sucked and I was
jealous at my right the whole thing was
[ __ ] up for you and I made it you
know what I did dude well I don't wanna
say it all right I won't you leave a bad
review on the show so no I was so loud
and obnoxious at the fight and I was I
was like kick his [ __ ] ass and being
somebody I'm not because I was that
insecure and the guy left and I know he
left because he was like this dude
next to me as an [ __ ] I was like I
was I was outside I said I love that guy
my favorite actor though he should be
and ie that's why I don't watch fights
with you I proved to be an [ __ ] I was
aggressive I was like a drunk dude at a
bar I'll [ __ ] kick your [ __ ] I was
doing that like I wanted a fight because
I was insecure
cuz he beat me on two fronts acting and
my wife would have left him me for him
that there is okay I admitted it well
it's a fun show I'm sorry I made it
about me dude I'll never watch the show
Hey
it will [ __ ] that show and I got a show
for you it's on history on demand is it
the with the things upon the kings of
pain it's two gentlemen an Australian
and a former I think he's like a marine
or some [ __ ] okay and they go around to
do a score of pain oh I'll do this thing
my second item oh yeah dude I will I
will watch dude they let a boa
constrictor buy them first he's been
testing yeah that's not a big deal to me
compared to like the Scorpion
centerpiece spiders but I mean I've been
baba watch the show did you sleep in a
bit by snake yeah what snake a Burmese
python and also double chorus oh but not
like these but yeah ya know why does it
really paint it's more painful than the
scorpion though the tarantula hawk well
I don't want to ruin it you got to watch
it you know I want to watch what's the
most simple thing for them if you can
watch showed everyone the centipede that
you should see these guys that they
fight with the coyote Peterson said it
was he got sick or something but here's
the thing that that that locust tree
that bites them it latches on and they
have to get like 18 stitches in their
[ __ ] arm that's a wild way I hate
those things scare me either what is
that horrifying that's a centipede yeah
they are harmed by it for centipede
[ __ ] you've been all over the world
have you seen one of those in a while
yes I have yeah I I've not only seen one
of those in the wild I saw one of those
in my house my father killed one of
those a huge one in Lebanon with his
bullish show scaring his book with his
book yeah I drop all any of the books go
away remember I live
in Pakistan in India there all those
different countries Philippines they get
they get bit by the real world what's
the worst like where nature's just so
you're like Fah Africa right well I
forgot but you know Pakistan in we there
were cobras we had cobras yeah we had to
charm them all kinds of snakes in Asia
like that yeah that will bite it'll kill
you and your and if you're a kid you're
God you know so sounds pretty bad - yeah
let's go somewhere in the Philippines
though and they're just like dude the
Philippines they catch some sort of wasp
in the Philippines and you can tell
they're not doing well
the Philippines tough dude the
Philippines is sad because like I'm very
squeamish of this stuff all the other so
fantastic that yeah really I'm gonna
wash up both both the hosts I'm gonna
walk right together and they get bit and
they have a they have a medical staff
on-site when they get bit by that
centipede then one dudes like he turns
all white and he's like I gotta lay down
he goes
you can tell it's really good [ __ ] do we
do the show why so what happens after he
gets bit by that do they just then shoot
him up with something okay no anti-venom
no they got a ride out like there's this
one I free what kind of ride these guys
could die a hundred percent that's what
a helical staff on site but the race
show but they're back
oh so here so that there's a beetle
where it's toxic
/ / like drip is way more venomous than
a cobra but the way it gets to you is so
you you it's in its blood so they they
say this beetle land on you people smash
it I don't think anything they smashed
it and then they just go about their day
but in his the toxins in his blood
that's what made all those that it so
it's like how sick is the executive who
thought this op who's [ __ ] in some
room in Beverly Hills I guess these why
don't we just have at like insects bite
people and see if they live well you
don't want that's our new show what is
that [ __ ] thing right there dude that
you talking about that wasp right that's
a trance walk what's that thing the trap
the tragical Hawk do they let any
spiders do it they have a trance or bite
them built the one with the big things
the Goliath
yeah whoa that kills the birds yeah
right bird-eating spider bites um it's
but it's not that venomous so they're
probably okay but it hurts like hell it
hurt
because it like you can see it's weird
he can hear piercing the skin twice yeah
yeah those those those boys are bad
those spiders are sighs with dinner
plate and they'll wrap around here's the
thing on there's pain index they do
initial pain then then the effects of
the bite and then how long it lasted
dude I'm gonna finish this when I you
know which one's the worst the simpie
centipede that why is the snakes number
one to this the cent most venomous was
the centipede what happened is the worst
is it like when the centipede bites you
is just the pain is it like local or
just like your whole body's just they
said their hope some you act local so
they give it a low score on the overall
and some it's just us some they said
last four days yeah the centipedes like
it's really dangerous really bad for you
it [ __ ] kills people
whole body oh you know what they did
they did us there's some sort of sea
urchin that's super poisonous and they
put their arms on and they have to get
to the they're short like little barbs
are the most poisonous so you have to
break this thing they're pushing it down
it's gonna stitch and then they hit it
oh dude it's insane would you let a
centipede bite you to reopen the economy
yes I think I would I would do a lot
name anything right now to him I would
probably do it go yeah [ __ ] I would a
now kid to if the counter is booming and
asked me do this show my girl goes how
much how much would you let how much
would it take for you to do this show
it's like alright I don't know cuz I'm
so scared of that snake the thing is you
have a kid it's different if you don't
have a kid right cuz you have a kid so
it's like heart like I sure I have a
motorcycle yeah some you gotta just
there's certain things you have to kind
of like we all live with levels of risk
but this seems like a high level of risk
there's that sea urchin that thing
[ __ ] them yeah that dude that does you
pick barbs in them this [ __ ] and then
the barbs get under the skin I'm gonna
see you don't wanna [ __ ] with this I can
see that you cannot mess with me that
shows fantastic throne fish I mean come
on I keep saying boys I wanna see get
bit by a rattlesnake I know somebody's
going to tell you I've been watching the
show I want to see your bass dangerous
over there they're too dangerous it's a
it's a venom that that gives in your
whole body I mean there's certain things
a wall hero talks these guys won't do
like the little they won't go to
Australia some of the things like
there's some of the things you know
Australia little scorpion fish yeah but
they
really they won't do the blue-ringed
octopus the blue-ringed all the time
they caught one and they go we can't
touch this you a doctor we would die
yeah but that's different
I don't want do an Amazon one of those
Amazon frogs where if you eat them yeah
and you become trans that's kind of cool
yeah you've been driving a lot of
science I'm I've heard of bridge
geologists I saw you just said that I
know you are but I just said if you look
it you'll become trans not into a [ __ ]
lick it you know we have gender
dysphoria no longer want to be that
you're born gender okay do you have
documentation on this I am an
invertebrate zoology I've seen this
happen in the Bois and said do you have
I've seen a man get licked by a frog and
then become a woman by the way it's
beautiful yeah the Frog likes the man
cuz I thought the man had to lick the
Frog there's a lot of licking going on
and that's exactly that's how you become
a trans person
okay oh you know what they do is they
get they get bit by the Velvet Bunny son
did that thought it was a cool aunt he
heard and that's what we give them in
California oh it's cutest [ __ ] that's
what I said
cutest [ __ ] dude is cute they are high I
want to stuff the heart though you know
you're full of [ __ ] huh they get big
like this oh dang
no that wasn't too bad coyote said they
were high all right well here's they
don't know parent a via comparatively
these guys getting bit by all kinds ah
it's a brand it's the new date you know
they're taking months up between bites
they get bit and they both kill not bad
it's the lowest on the score oh my god
he goes are like a honey bees oh one the
things I guess three for them so what
about look at that [ __ ] so what is the
worst wasp they say besides trash flow
uh can you bring it up the executioner
wasp is a head of the transfer was what
about like a great white shark that
should be season dear Isley that'll take
your leg off
well that's season two how are they
gonna top this
there was a guy who wanted to put a suit
on like a giant bite suit and [ __ ] with
a grizzly um it's a terrible idea
yeah but Dad I think he died well cuz
they break walls bones right snap his
neck well it was like really fortified
you know okay but yeah you're gonna get
[ __ ] would they let a person bite them
that season too
nobody's developing up to three and a
bullet instead of four and that's the
highest so that's why I'm saying this is
there what's a warrior wasp all their
torture these you are changing you
already come warrior wasps
cuz when they're on the when they're
about to attack them they start clapping
their wings so it sounds like a tribe
going all at the same time these
creatures that matter it's not that
shows fantastic though this is why I am
for companies destroying the planet
because these things need to go well
well but that's kind of a blanket
shutdown is yes there are some cute
furry things that I'm going to go as
well but a lot of these things are gonna
you gonna have one pet what would it be
oh great question I enjoy the capybara
bars are good
[ __ ] the largest rodent rodent it's
just a fun conversation starter it is
horrible
tell me you would not walk around there
they're the favorite dish of the
non-whites people but they're also
Africa yeah but they're oh no that were
the indigenous to an Amazon Amazon the
Amazon so they are they favorite dish of
the spear chuckers because in the Amazon
that's not racist they have tribes okay
they do yeah but that's they do the
there but there's own animals that loves
a couple Condor dealer yacon oh no
crocodiles Tiger Tigers aren't a part of
the Anaconda they're not there they're
not there the young guys the young Wow
oh yeah yahuwah
right okay look at how cute he is look
at her teeth yeah that's a giant it's
just like one of those tea I think
there's like a lot of shows now where
it's like I finally pass yeah I think
I'll see has a lot of those shows I
think it's cute as [ __ ] I don't trust
him with PLC's like to normalize a watch
reality Channel look how cute their
favorite show on TLC is 90-day fiance
and the thousand-pound sisters yeah and
then they'll be like I married my pet
chicken and you're like okay but I
wanted to roll yeah 14 he's great
somewhere in the bowels of TLC they're
like we need to find the most destroyed
people on the planet and make shows know
all TLC does is they have some staff
that watches YouTube and go ride good
show good ideas like jazz the the the
the little boy would turn into a girl
that was a bit she had a huge YouTube
follow guys Jennings yes yeah the the
thousand-pound sisters were big YouTube
before the show yeah that's all they're
doing 600 people popper was huge online
so big fat fabulous life oh it is dr.
pimple popper she actually pimp pops
like blackheads that have been yep
dormant for like most of all though
should do like huge stuff though sake
sort of had life they all have
significant others which is great it
made crazy no one single yeah dude it's
amazing
have you watched their on TV i watch
this too hot to handle no what is what
is know like the dating what's you show
what the little people when they are
always fighting oh that was i think it's
called the little pig yeah little okay
to hunt animals that they bait they put
always really hot people on the island
what are you doing my time you can't
have sex what are you doing watching it
was just a I was watching her those
bored and that turned it off how did you
watch the love is blind you know I got
for episode then I was it kind of over
this oh yeah I just watched all things
it was porn Tina's look whatever did you
like it it's fine I like the black girl
she's out with the white guy she's cured
yeah yeah and then was like my family I
don't know how I'm gonna feel about this
because they're like so Pro black yeah
they've never even seen a black white
person she has to bring him home right
but the dudes on it we're not I don't
know that some of them were good-looking
some of them were lying about that one
guy was like I have a secret to tell
he's like he's like well I'm gay I did
meet her eyes and she's like why is [ __ ]
yeah they get in the biggest fight yeah
issue if you're oh that's okay he's gay
no that's the one who had to go to the
black girl's house it's still working I
was like they're like Black Panthers
there yeah it's working out though is it
working
yeah they're still together or not dude
this chick up here was like you could
tell the pop right that's right yeah
this girl was like you could tell like
the sporty chick in school that was
popular and then with just a weird chick
I've never got a dude and she's a
thirsty super thirsty super strange uses
the word random a lot but she's like is
Iran I'm like shift five friends I got
the deal was very hard to deal with
drinks her weight booze so she got with
this short connect with this guy but
he's real sure she hate it I'm not
attracted to him so she hated he was
like five four oh yeah they met she
wants some guys did would [ __ ] her in in
in college at 3 a.m. dropped like none
of them want to marry you you're 36 it's
over
find the little fat dentist or the short
time who the you're him but like she's
yet like this two six foot three athlete
she's definitely one of those special
day guy though I was like I have a
secret she's like just tell me whatever
you want how bad can it be he's like
yeah well I'm gay yeah and she they
almost got a physical why I mean yeah
yeah sue is wild is that a mint kind of
a mint uh nicotine you love them anybody
ever mint you know what it is I'm
tasting my chocolate in my mouth from
the mom one other puffing I want another
muffin do you boys it's still in my
throat either another muffin it's it
there's no judgment why don't come out
of this quarantine castable and hot we
got start tomorrow I've started tomorrow
for a very those muffins are very good
they're very soft and I bet they're
healthy but the chocolate side there all
right right you know what though their
muffins though you know that you're not
what's in them that is even bad frozen
chocolate we losses from Sardinia flower
feta cheese notes we raised our squid
Anna's there's a banana in it so there's
pnom have something as like on
healthiest food and you know why because
everything
in is also horrific for you so it's like
flat like Bananas Foster cousin Anne is
never anything that's remotely huh it's
never like banana salad it's always like
banana french toast
nice graze yeah it's bananas like of
dessert food it's a [ __ ] like a bananas
a [ __ ] food it's true it's a dirty
[ __ ] food who wants to get chocolate
syrup but once again sugar once I get
flan paid yeah at least an apple like
little pie up but they'll also throw it
in a salad with some corn it's all up
your lower side walnut yeah the walnut
in a pie up yeah it'll pie up the heart
blueberries too though you might toss
them on a salad blueberries aren't there
they like that image strawberries are a
little stare a little like a salad by
let's think I'm a [ __ ] a little [ __ ]
raspberries are straight up like we're
[ __ ] yeah because they want in
desserts they want a jam they want in
jam and they wanted desserts and deserve
every now and then a razz broke onto a
vinaigrette but it's like stop because
then that salad is worse than anything
else too sweet a raspberry vinaigrette
salad there's always like warm hot goat
cheese a crostini it's a CAF bread yes
bacon it's like yeah yeah walnut again
but there's nothing quite like a banana
because a banana is just a dirty [ __ ]
fruit because you know why it needs to
be frozen with chocolate all over it
yeah well pops honey mango also just all
sugar
yes but you know what is a revelant yeah
you never have somebody go you want a
papaya ever you're a worldly guy I don't
like if you're me pop guy as I get idea
why did you throw a pie because if
you're a club man I'm gonna make an
American citizen yeah great I mean how
dare you I'm sorry I do not live in
Pakistan okay my enemies with all places
I haven't been fire is a private a nice
slice of pine
you know it's dirty what about coconut
what's the feeling about Coco cuz they
do the water we're gonna water healthy
little sugar though yeah and they also
try to get into the desert
depending on good man I think it'll to
saturate infinite oil
yeah what's the best fruit I'll get a
flock tomato mine tomato hock forget it
cause he's smart I know he's gonna get
it Tomas the best fruit because it is
it's got I like the nice tomato man like
a little cherry specially when it's
cooked they say when you cook tomato
it's actually better for you that's for
your prostate really yes
my grandmother was from the Bronx didn't
all of their breakfast they used to have
like a fried tomato I was like a big
deal to like tomato in the pan are you
Irish miss New York not really anymore
I say I do cuz I like the idea of
sounding like I miss you all I suck in
but I don't I don't give a [ __ ] at all
but I want to seem like I'm smart and
I'm like a hardened guy so like I say
like yeah New York who would be
different I would truly I don't care I
actually have suggested gas in all of
New York and killing them to get rid of
the front of ours not burning the
buildings not gas huh not with the bomb
because that would hurt the architecture
kills all the organic not the bill kills
the life yeah I said we should do do get
rid of New York to people and keep the
buildings and repopulate that's hard
over Tim California Jim don't you feel
like I was who ever since you came out
here and you're yeah successful to see a
lot of other New York comedians you know
started doing the same thing
some of them will but some of them get a
date you get addicted to New York man
New York ship drug New York's a drug so
the energy in New York should drug you
know because for a week for a while here
before like I was still getting stuff
happening like you come out here and
then that you're like you're in New York
you just run a million miles and then
you come out here and they're just it's
the Energy's like it's like you take it
down and then you like cut because you
could fall into depression super easy
but then you're like okay no there's a
hustle here just a different hustle the
hospital you can you do it and you can
figure it out but New York is just boom
boom boom boom
but in a world where stand-up might be
less prevalent I mean a lot of people
are gonna have to figure out a digital
thing they got to figure it out they got
to figure out whether it's a pond you
think Stan is gonna be back full swing
where people are doing this last weekend
all grown and spoke in yeah I would say
full swing like that full swing meaning
there's like packed out shows everywhere
and I hope I'm not right I
don't want to be right August a year
from right now Oh your I don't want to
be right I just said I don't want to be
right [ __ ] but I'm saying full swing
again and all kinds of heating I I don't
want to be right here
but do you really reason I'm saying that
is because I don't see what changes
between now and October or now and
whatever by herd immunity
now we're not winnowing near that
nobody's had this nobody's even had us
ton of people have it more people than
you think in California especially maybe
but it's you know heard of mean these
80% of population our population is 300
plus million people 50 million oh I hope
to god I'm wrong I hope to god I'm back
on out on the road soon I hope they're
like hey we have this great antiviral
what it's doing is like you know
basically keep keeping this thing in a
box if you get it you take this you're
good well hope to god if comedies if
you're right which I think you're
totally off all right I hope I under
right we're not back to next year 2020
yeah your favorite comedy clubs won't be
there for you to correct yeah but I I'm
looking at restaurants like that I'm
looking at comedy clubs I'm looking at I
think your shots gonna do takeout food
and the King kind of survives some of
them have said it's really hard
restaurants make all their money on
booze they make all their money on the
margins on booze there's nothing to do
it a couple east they have some avenue
yeah but they're gone like a wrestling
good we're gonna come up with a creative
way to deal with this we're gonna come
up with a guy I think the comedy will be
back I'm sorry I and I think what's
gonna happen we're gonna do some I
attitude we're not listening right we
might have rooms that are 100 people
first then 150 yeah and then and then
I'll do a show right now I'll go do an
outdoor show if there was an outdoor
show right now cinema I would do I would
do anything like you said I didn't come
people are gonna go I'll take my chances
where do I sign [ __ ] bill rice goes
yellow shut Palm Beach right now it's
sellout I believe it
yeah let's but here's a day of a [ __ ]
we're gonna watch these dates right
we're gonna watch these states we're
gonna see when they open up I'm okay
it's like oh yeah who everyone I talked
to I'm liking the mascot I'm so ready
for this to be over there I now dude
yeah we all awesome I chose that friend
who's a cotton she's like dude I'm just
talking to people hospitals you tell me
to go listen if we have to keep treating
culvert pages ambulances won't come we
won't be able to treat anything
it's gonna be a disaster will be a
capacity with a lotta capacity too but
that's because we've been in our house
correct but if we go out of our houses
and this goes crazy puttin that but now
we round up we're the the ventilators
later on even the vendors aren't even
the way to handle this like the
ventilators a lot of people are saying
it's making it worse I'm hoping that
we're where we listen I'm hoping you're
right I'm just saying the whole reason
we've done this is the fear is that the
exponential growth of this will
hospitalized too many people at once for
the whole system I'll be like why don't
you move to Wuhan do cuz you're
obviously oh yeah I know it's how much
time a child I'm a Chinese I'm I gotta
be honest with you you just outed me I'm
secretly Chinese that's a comedy can't
come back as we know it's the most
important industry in the well did you
read it as goes comedy as goes the
country did you read that the trend they
think Chinese agents were what's a
Chinese agents Chinese agents okay no
that's a that's a we're releasing false
information and trying to panic our hour
as a New York Times article the New York
Times bullish
no it's not [ __ ] they'd a bumpy a
newer closer yeah no your time says
their research post fools for them to
put out that that we think the Chinese
agent trying to you miss priority we're
creating we're creating hysteria where
were pet were sending we're sending so
many texts with like things like it's
gonna shut this yeah oh and she told me
in street that the the Department
Homeland Security had to issue things
that said this is fake news story
freaked out so this is this is pretty
interesting and knowing that once that
went on yeah I support it
I support China the true leader of the
worldwide I'm going with the winner
China oh my gosh
they'll put people and earn stress the
ding okay we're soft
China becau you have it out of here and
I do i do hope through all this one one
thing that might become positive is we
start taking back a lot of stuff and
more stuff as you I think more stuff
needs to be made in America right we
should be so dependent on China you
should need to make more stuff in
America shitty about they're not our
friends they're not I'm talking about
the China war doesn't feel
he knows really if you want to go that
way or what because charlie be Dolly B
is a restaurant okay they serve
spaghetti and hot dog and fried chicken
it's very confused okay very confusing
so if you're looking at like what's a
way to confuse people just con she's
full of fat people Filipino agents know
that they're like what if we had a
restaurant they're just a food that
didn't even make sense where the chefs
are raccoon essentially just throwing in
a bunch of garbage so this is what we're
that's what we're dealing with okay man
I don't know dude this has been a very
like your science I have the facts bring
those O Lord from Rogan cuz we expect
that's it I know facts matter facts
matter when you look at a guy like me
you go he's got the facts that's right
yeah he's gotta stand outside of my
shows they go this guy's got the fastest
second that's facts we make a statement
that's completely not true and this is
how we always get out of it okay
my father does this all the time he'll
say something that's completely provably
untrue about something is gonna happen
in the future we go why do you think
that he goes watch why then he's done
like what do you mean he goes watch it's
a way to win he wins and he's like he'll
be like that [ __ ] happen he goes like
this that business he goes that business
going out of business there we go what
do you mean they're killing it every
night he goes watch walked into another
15 years ago had an old black guy go
like this to me I've never forgot it
I was his old black guy said he said
enjoy your freedom now and I said what
do you mean he goes no he said enjoy
your privacy now I said what do you mean
he goes you see that camera there was a
camera it was a traffic camera and he
goes in ten years
everywhere you go you will be on camera
and I went ok right I do love your
spirit see that project that he was so
prescient that he saw the fact that no
matter where we go we will always be
able that's what wasn't preaching
usually bring here's what's read the
reality was coming Ted Kaczynski
there's gonna be fully autonomous cities
where people gonna buy into a city it's
gonna be sterilized all your health
information all of your personal
information your credit information
social media it's all gonna be logged in
you're gonna get a face will be
recognized yeah
facial recognition you're nothing you'll
be no more physical marketplaces you
will not go to a store everything will
be delivered to you everything you do
will be tracked there will be no
automobile ownership you're gonna get in
a fleet of self-driving cars everything
is going to be engineered the simulation
it's gonna be it's gonna be wild dude
we're not gonna see a lot of it but the
beginning of it because a friend of mine
works at Deutsche Bank because we're
already looking at the financial
infrastructure it's really a torch back
he goes fully autonomous term cities
meaning that you would buy him in the
city like you wouldn't buy a home in
Santa Monica you would buy cinema you do
it into a into a it's like a condo into
a crap into a condo thing but again its
approval will require all of the things
Health social media they're looking to
be like well we don't want a lunatic
who's going crazy in social media here
how healthier you like because you're
gonna be using all of the you're gonna
be using all the public all your data
will be available I think however be
while dude it's gonna be a wild world
we're gonna be yeah well the person will
be then then they'll sell services to
make your data private then they'll be
privacy movements they're gonna be towns
where it's like we do things the
old-fashioned way we're old-school
whatever it is but I do think you're
right I think I mean it's too convenient
to do that I'm a futurist and I study
future systems part of what I do on part
of what I do is study the integration of
technology at a future point where
technology will integrate with and then
future systems will arrive right and
part of what I'm doing right now is
looking at how the pandemic has except
is going to accelerate a lot of the
things that we've seen so self-driving
cars fully autonomous cities by odomes
people living out of pods [ __ ] robots I
mean as much as we're kidding around
about all this it is kind of true ahead
okay that's why I had it was blowing
things up he was hauling things up he
knew he knew we're not honest he called
it a tease he called I had a guy talking
about how we're gonna have people will
use drones and print plastic 3d guns let
them just kill people you know thoughts
have everything they need crazy and
they'll fly a drone the next mass
shootings gonna be from a drone by some
[ __ ] how about there's a mass
shooting at Santa and nose gonna make
any new 16 people 25 get to barely
anyone know why driving around right I
don't know can you look that up it's
weird to me there haven't been any masks
and knock on wood but there because
people are getting together so he get a
mass shoot no I know but there's people
you come on - but I'm glad that we're
not having that right now that's he well
10 10 bucks says the guy was white is
[ __ ] Walter oh he's probably just
angry and mad and crazy yeah you think
my circuit being can you imagine like I
mean it's just crazy to me taking the
lives of that many people it's so he set
fire to the crime scenes that's so fun
51 years old one teenage girl what a
piece of [ __ ] did you guys have animal
he was very real look he's a denturist a
denturist what the hell is that is that
like a dentist dude some mistake so he
said makes dancer he said SIA structure
on fire and the victims were believed to
be inside and burned out buildings I
mean the guy's a monster and Canada will
not put this man to death some of them
were known to get all warm and were
targeted what I think what what goes on
with mass ratings very rare they
survived
it's very rare they survive they usually
shoot themselves to get shot by the cops
Cho do we have a picture I've always
white don't you want to see him yeah
they never they stop putting pictures
out however since the Dylan the oh
really
Lee bald the kid in the dark night
shooting or yeah they don't want on the
back it was was a different guy that was
thinking after that happen how were you
when that happened I don't know when did
that happen call mine I was in high
school we were our school got shut down
oh by the way everybody just really
quick there's a side note I know that we
were saying 71 inches was 5-9 that's
what the [ __ ] computer says what it
meant was it was 5.9 of six yes everyone
say means it's worth I'm fine you're
fine that yeah that's the shooter no no
this guy here this yeah of course
god what a piece of [ __ ] dude to be able
just go crazy or is he always wanted
something's got a snap right doesn't
something grab him he's a dentist
oh my [ __ ] rest' that's so weird so
you're gonna wonder with this shut down
right
did it affect his ability like was yun
medicine still more diddles more if it
wasn't the corn baby I don't know did he
is he just what does it like it is a
man's go masses no mad because his
hairline maybe but maybe he just went
crazy he went mad and maybe he just
couldn't like maybe he was on a medicine
he couldn't get like maybe there was
something that sparked this you're a
[ __ ] mental health professional I do
a lot of work with it's more psychiatry
and psychology okay because I study the
brain I am more more neurology
psychology Asian yeah psychologist is
kind of like [ __ ] work I do like like I
look in the brain and see what's up
he was obsessed the Mounties had alcohol
promise for all his business was shut
the fort shut down because a corona girl
well you know you know that campaign ad
that's coming he was just a normal
dangerous I know he was shut down by
coronavirus see what happened open
society she's pregnant yeah but the
thumbs up
hey dude society there we got manscaped
and we got mountain bikes right there to
things that we deal with yep interesting
that's what knows what's going on well
specialize too are they listening to us
well Jim probably research at Google
they probably go are you some kind of
events let me let me pee out of my sure
go piss thanks out of your [ __ ] let's do
some current events current events of
Tim Timmy Timmy Dillon colleges so you
guys talked about this earlier with the
actor Ansel Elgort
the other day is he yeah Hannah
Montana's boyfriend no that's an oily
Cyrus yeah that's very similar I don't
know they all look the same
Jerry no I have kind of a look I can he
posted this photo she was taken by his
dad I believe yes and he had in the
caption only fans Lincoln bio and when
you click on the link it's actually a
GoFundMe page that'll help Brooklyn
based nurses get food during this
pandemic okay I'm about to do this but
I'm going to take picture me in the
shower
art in my hogs in me kind of like that
and I'm ago only fans only clicking the
bow through my thick boy t-shirts yeah
that's good vibe man that's kind of
uncool this is you dick
no I'm gonna be sober and I'm a bulldog
that's up the back sure I'm gonna do it
have it like this huh that's it you know
obviously you cannot be squeezing your
balls in [ __ ] like this with two hands a
puzzle yeah so it's all bubbled up like
that like this lines in the brains and
say who's in the brains and bat wings
yeah and then we'll say Oh brain just
says brains and bat wings and just let
them figure it out is only dot-com and
then click on Big Boy yep and Tim is
taking a dump in the toilet behind us
let's do it smart good idea well that's
tight he raised money though yeah I love
it there the fourth story down was Ansel
Elgort spotted dancing at slave play
party it's like there was a show on
Broadway about slavery and at the other
party I guess he was dancing it's like
oh maybe that man it's just kind of
hilarious like just being up in like
party it's called the slave plan it's
[ __ ] great
yeah I saw him play this guy he looks
he's a good-looking dude but he looks a
little rain where is he from Sweden he's
from a socialite family New York City's
dad's big photographer you know on so
Elgort on so on so I do a bit where I go
I'm dating and then the next day I go on
so I'll go broke up with me and then I
could dated she would again I go we're
back together they do different year
just the idea that he would tweet it cuz
like listen to this I tweet I'm now in a
relationship a little Zen little Zen
tweets it retweets it and then follows
really yeah if he doesn't know what he's
doing the whiz that is a phenomenal yet
spider is on so and Spiderman act really
with no that's Tom whatever so what is
what is he a socialite this kid an
actress a baby driver he's in everything
he's a good actor he's right he loves
himself he's right into him hey I like
when Rogen was like dude what'd he say
Bill Gates gonna is gonna hit you up man
you say in this show you like I hope he
help me and Bill Gates are in a big
fight but no he's
about that actually by some of you but
the reality is I'm a comedian I'm here
to bring levity to a troubled world yes
that's a reality we also use fact can I
use facts and I know stuff because I'm a
smart boy yeah but you know
cross-reference what I see has to be a
Native American woman / before you need
yes and the reality is I John Stefano
Rogan
watch watch watch gonna dude no one that
I grew up with his ever spoken with a
fact
no one's ever science always that's
always started the show yeah like never
once at nobody and Rogan used to say
stuff and people would [ __ ] Paul do
we get death threats over our Korona
talk Jay gets them all the time they see
me Jay goes reading so many death
threats on Khurrana me death threat
death threats
Jay who about what about I'm not saying
not to always hear about of it you get
death threats over that oh you met Jay
yeah we're not saying that be careful
though he's just Dallas stealth
what are they saying just that we should
we hope you die oh people radical we're
not trying to maybe a corona we're not
really bro I'm taking it lightly we're
just not everybody's I'm just I'm not
doing anything I shouldn't do I'm going
to Bristol Farms once a week
I'm doing podcast but I'm not going out
and being stupid I go to bath houses and
that's it that's yeah and I belong to a
wrestling I go through LAX and just make
videos I make videos in the ER Cedars I
don't do anything crazy oh you know
crazy stuff how great was it onmy
Whitney Cummings brought the food to the
nurses and it snapped the photo of
ourselves doing it that's funny it's
great because that's why we did it
it's I would not have thought like if we
didn't take the photo I would member of
daughter okay so a woman survived a
bullet wound to the chest because of her
fake impotence did it yep so a bullet
went into the left side of her chest
rooo the silicone and the silicone
actually ricocheted the bullet away from
her heart through to her right breast
allegedly cuz we don't really know but I
like the story yeah she just got hit on
the side where you know I'm saying
George like that
yeah I should hate her huh no she's got
hit very far from her heart and the
bullet well looks like that that the
breast implants punctured yeah could
have that is an implant man that's an
implant hey yeah hey scroll up tis on
the site it said teen from breast
implants gets brain damage boob job
allegedly left Colorado teen brain
damage well you're a teen right getting
your boobs done that cat sister just
kidding boob job damn it's terrible what
how bad bad is a brain damage ah well it
could be something up with the
anesthesia things go wrong listen she
gets over into cardiac arrest she could
probably have a pretty good life if she
just smiled and nodded well she's
beautiful yeah I was a lot of dudes to
give it up that's an advertisement for a
lot of dudes she's brain damaged big
tits nice looking yeah Sam you're being
super insensitive right now all right
well she guys dead so the New York the
mayor of New York City actually set up a
line where you can text photos of people
who are breaking social distancing and
that line would have been flooded with
the blessings of peace Hitler memes all
of this like de Blasio is a [ __ ]
donut he is he sucks I'm glad that this
happened I can hate I hate society
becoming rats is there anything worse
nothing works if people weren't will the
the governor and you know they asked for
it here to in California Gavin yeah John
your fellow news and Garcetti and Gavin
they also discuss on your neighbor get
the glass here look at that look at this
[ __ ] yeah hey thanks for making us
safe but we're setting up a snitch line
you are a snitch Allah your snitch if I
went to the teacher all the time [ __ ]
hate that yeah in tax you 75% people are
he's a [ __ ] wants to yeah I know he
wants oh yeah a piece of [ __ ] you socks
man he's a socialist but California
don't know one do the same thing and if
you didn't go people don't respond well
to it now snitch on our neighbor on
snitch you a couple [ __ ] that do its
own take my picture at the coffee shop I
have a mask
but uh most people did they'll get a lot
of [ __ ] blowback and should have and
they shut it down after all the [ __ ]
picks and they're good good good reason
why people were angry about this is cuz
a couple days before he launched this
line he was caught at a gym working out
yeah of course he's a [ __ ] he's a
tyrannical piece of [ __ ] they all like
he's all living at the we're all liars
this is what my thing with the
government is I don't trust anybody
because I kinda know the people that
rise to these positions for the most
part a lot of these people are you know
you don't want to trust them I agree
these are politics I'm not gonna do it
dude you're an ugly actor dude I love
how I love a tacky they were like you've
never you've never had it run a business
where you had to make your own money
because yeah I run a huge business and
he was material here's the problem dude
you don't have to come up with a profit
no yeah paid regardless you don't run
New York City dummy you make decisions
but what are you out of your mind
York City's been running itself for a
while yeah de Blasio you're wrong but
yeah he's just left last the government
official I trust with Jeff came saw how
that ended doing with straight-up dude I
go even before that the last guy I
trusted was Warren Harding last man that
cuz he put a casino in the White House
that's a guy I trust I trust that's a
guy who goes we're not even playing
around anymore dude how about Obama put
a basketball court in though yeah well
that has its custom for some yeah but
that's what you say - I said that's an
interesting way to her did you say black
team is a black move to put a basketball
court Obama I would say the blackest you
know there's nothing wrong with that
a white guy would've put a golf thing in
we should all do what we do what else
get Jen then you do a commercial rap
recently who did you Rappaport oh yeah I
was like I did a rap yeah that's it I
mean rapport didn't you were on set for
this me I just got there but I didn't
see it alright so what is this yeah so
this is a script that I rewrote which I
played ourselves got planar but I don't
like people don't come here like the
word which part angry uptight jerk yeah
that's that's not who I am you know who
I am in real life yeah you're great so
then like you're doing your thing
what thing what thing you know him to
think that not Percy I judge the roast
next on once I'm being Michael Rapaport
yeah do we not speak like when there's
camp senior movies very funny friendship
he's a lot so you'd love him yeah I
guess we can walk yeah I'll bring in the
peer spectrum CVD right and then I just
drop your mouth like a little baby bird
you take it and they just it chills me
out you're good okay so at what point do
you want me to chill you know what I
don't like the way this is going and you
see this your words see this is what you
did that hurt you eat your chest while
you're here why I'm here is I'm walking
off the set so I'm not here that's good
now I'm playing that character that's
what I like the angry guy hell yeah dude
ladybirds
angry brother that's perfect man I love
rapport you guys we get along great
can I get some sometimes I get a lower
back thing and I don't want to take
over-the-counter anti-inflammatories can
I get some CBD cream yeah oh yeah of a
whole package right because I just I
want it some time here the lower back
thing I don't want to take
over-the-counter anti-inflammatories
because they're bad to lower your immune
system all kinds of punches on so I'd
like to do a little summary there's
somebody with strong hands who's got the
antibodies yeah all right all right we
had some good news stories today oh you
see this one
Spanish taxi driver so I guess he's been
getting free rides for Crowe Navarro no
virus patients to the hospital and then
the hospital and the nurses and doctors
all applauded him when he got there and
then surprise him with it
the give him a check gave him a check
and also tested him and apparently he's
negative it's a very tall guy to please
the tallest guy is he's seven foot
I I mean I'm not trying to be a dick is
disease happening why are they all doing
dying in a room right now because these
people are clapping for this how much
the check was for I don't but it's very
sweet we better find a vaccine already
so I can pay for the Spanish bathrobe
and he was moved to tears obviously it's
great now go back out there and catch it
I'll get the work he just caught it
stays cool that is cool he's a good man
right there it's a good man I'd like a
few of those people to be a work yeah so
you'd come break it up I would go guys
you know I don't really pay attention
show T that's Tampa Bay Tom in a
superball
yeah grunt ow ski they have such good
players there win the super old man then
it's got Gronkowski they're gonna be
such fun yeah they're gonna be beasts
Percy Harvin's gonna go croc was so done
with it weird because you have that
video over there god I dunno yeah we
start crying alright but they're
thinking part of its just bill Chuck is
such an [ __ ] no wants to play for WoW
so here's I told up I can get out demand
a trade and went to Tampa Bay oh yeah
and then uh Tom Brady posted this
afterwards
time to run a back rub a little time
that's hot as nice well you guys
remember Shawn Weiss that dude from
Mighty Ducks which is not him he got all
myth now fat one this guy
Oh remember he was a Mighty Duck star
yeah he was the fat kid yeah he was a
fat kid and then oh we saw this like
pretty recently a few months ago and
want to try meth yeah and then his buddy
was another actor I guess rocked
actor/model he he helped him out a big
time and then check him out right now no
this isn't no good jack I would run if I
saw that kind of street that's a tough
question
let's say it says meth bust finally look
well I think our definition of the
hell's on the man yeah for sure
what's long his friend yeah my piece you
just wanted to picture next day ugly
guys so what do you say that I do see
him like he's walking on news stations
he's a good but he seems like he's been
helping out a lot though so you know
after that shot was taken that the guy
just looks you guys he's like Holly he's
like not touching him and then he goes
like this because we're good oh god it
goes
he just backs away he's right in the car
you'll see you next week since what yeah
yeah tough times this is cool the Venice
canals had a jellyfish swim through it
she's real cool the only thing we had to
do is destroy the world economy I see
one more of these videos and pure insane
I'm gonna Bob gonna Club a dolphin with
a with a [ __ ] bat if one more idiot
goes now we have dolphins in the canals
the people vanish are about to eat their
relatives no money and I mean it's just
like the it's just the idiocy of like
wealthy environmentalists like these la
people in Malibu thing like isn't it
nice that the dog it's like shut up
look here that water's Tim behind it
yeah but but your other mods but but all
of it many people have jobs yeah
straight up to die
this is not a trade off like people keep
talking about the environment reset an
environment that yeah a bit of a break
you know Delhi is the [ __ ] New Delhi is
like the most polluted city of all time
and it's like they had a civet hadn't
seen in 50 years running through the
streets that's great this is going viral
this girl looks like JLo she's a
bodybuilder JLo that's not JLo
no that's Jaime it's actually like a
feminine looking grow this picture looks
super buff and yeah thanks ever alright
that's right there I guess you know it's
makeup and stuff yeah she's also got a
hot sir on the left
no sorry there's another picture another
she is hot yeah that's well that one she
looks like JLo and the rest she doesn't
yeah
don't Iran she's a [ __ ] smoke show
she kind of looks like her there it's
here in the now you know J Lo's got them
eyes and Matt's right corner spot by the
Mets behind them at you like that Hamid
you're gonna get food well she's missing
for you as a giant [ __ ] a little too
much for about I like and that's the
most
oh hello back oh well yeah I'm I'm a fan
she's super hot those two years ago yeah
throwback so she was buffer then I guess
and that's what she looks like now faces
I like the way she looks now mm-hmm she
little to shred City for me all right
this is a this is a very sweet one this
is a world World War two veteran and
then his carer she's 17 years old she
gave him a gift I guess he would always
go to sleep with a photo his wife who
passed away nine months ago so this is
his care giving him a gift she gave him
an gotta ruin everything
the pillow of his wife you gotta find
out she's taking $40,000 I was checking
a cat they stole his car she
takes his card everyday and she takes
that $600 lawyers yeah sad oh my god
he's taking the road she was younger
that's a great [ __ ] gift I know so
sweet she's 17 years old she thought of
this it's a simple gift
now there's another I posted a sweet one
up this little this little kid he's a
toddler he has Down syndrome and he's
freaking out during the quarantine and
then they bring his newborn brother to
the dad and it finally gets them to calm
down I guess he's just been freaking
them yes we're in quarantine is Ryan
strong it's on Twitter oh it's on your
Twitter it's super sweet though man it's
a pretty handsome picture which one
change your change your Instagram pic I
should do that first time me and his
brother look
they say they can't get to calm down
finally this newborn brother comes look
[Music]
Wow Daisy that's my name is crazy that's
very very cute and sad
so she have kids just enjoy it this is
the quarantine I was very sad is the
father looked at the kid with Down
syndrome II looked at the other kidneys
like I'm here to provide a small amount
of levity I have in the world that's
gone mad I don't know I I wish everyone
the best you know sort of I thought that
the stimulus should have been more given
more get more but nobody what's this a
last one this is a nature's metal
obviously and this is a snake eating a
wrap with the right eating its way out
of the snake oh my god and if the snake
is still moving to you is that a
rattlesnake yeah this Santa Monica
minority's Santa Clarita oh yeah they're
out now it's a gopher Steve yesterday on
my bike I heard two rattlesnakes scared
shitless you know what is how does his
hand no no yeah I really loved I would
help that rat out well you know the rest
the rider it would pull the rest dad
yeah but it was chewing its way out and
finally chewed it I want to see a rat
then nobody wants to die that way we're
stuck with a [ __ ] snake little rat
though you know let him go the snake is
still not sure why you killed snake I
was in a - and then I [ __ ] pull that
step that I pull that rats head right
out of that Stu dangerous I'll let
nature do after me it's not I let nature
do its no word if that [ __ ] that's why I
carry scissors with me it says mr.
nibbles died in the process but he can
rest easy so one of the things I had I
had a [ __ ] where I had my oh they
both died yeah when I have my pythons
they used to say Oh be careful cuz the
rat if it's a big enough route it can
kill your snake Oh I told you my buddies
in college did a boa constrictor and
go hey man we're on vacation can you
feed the rat can you feed the snake on
it yeah no doubt so I go to the pet
store and they go we don't have any mice
man we have this rat I went I'll take
that [ __ ] rat
dude I tossed that rat in there went
home big two weeks later he came back
from vacation
well that rat ate the snake dude uh-huh
it bit his head off and ate this thing
come in this the rat was off who else
wants so yeah so [ __ ] around
don't mad at me yeah I had no idea
how's it going the whole lot more
specific what do you want I'm not
herpetologist until until I mean I swear
they know what I was doing they they do
we have rats on I'll take that thick ass
rat that'll keep him fed here you grew
up with pets I had a couple of cats my
mother said she was allergic to dogs
which was probably alive I always wanted
a dog and I might get one now get one I
thought we were I was gonna be in the
road every week I wouldn't need one but
I know I might get one but cuz then we
go back on the road you can just leave
it all the time that's smart that's why
I'm a knockout I might foster one for a
month or two a few months I just got a
text my buddy who's gonna get her he
wants good dog but he wants germ Sarah
it's not gonna bite but it looks like
it's gonna bite ya it's like police dogs
they'll get a dog that after training
after like 10 11 months they find it's
just a dud it's not gonna bite you too
nice and those are grateful to put them
on you were smart meanwhile though
they're still you can train them do
anything so my buddy's like I want 15
grand
15 get ripped yeah that dog do
everything that dog will do calc
derivatives for you that's crazy man it
change it
those were good Tim thanks for being
brave extra having me yes sir I
appreciate we can they fun you Dylan Tim
Dylan show on YouTube and wherever you
get podcasts and also Tim Jay Dylan di
ll o n at Instagram Twitter you know
great you got to make a shirt that says
fax I should you're a beast
well I appreciate that our favorites
thank you I have the facts man I put the
work in
do I do my due diligence yeah and I
don't spout off about nonsense know what
I mean that's the man that's the main we
appreciate you enlighten me thank you I
appreciate it
that it that's him your dates be we have
Spokane Spokane brother just went on
sale t5k dot-com yeah we're going to
last week in a June get um smoke in
let's do the mine writes this the fired
kid brow